so i spent the last year with these
keyboards and since they gave me a very
different experience i wanted to share
my thoughts on how to pick the right
keyboard and how the right keyboard can
have a considerable impact on your
productivity and comfort hey guys my
name is danny and i'm an architect and
youtuber from vancouver bc and i type a
lot
and today with the help of my assistants
i want to show you which keyboard could
be the right fit for you
this video is sponsored by short form
more on them later in this video times
have changed in the past a keyboard was
an essential peripheral before the mouse
and ui were invented there were no other
ways to communicate with the computer so
that means no keyboard no party i don't
even need a fancy keyboard who cares
about colors anyway
who cares about the switches
shut up but nowadays the experience of
buying a keyboard is a really tailored
experience and the level of aesthetic
customization and tech and comfort
options
can be a little bit overwhelming
so i chose these three keyboards because
they provide a very diverse experience
and they're based on different typing
technologies we've got the 10
wired membrane keyboard i'm sure it
works fine
the fully mechanical wireless newfie air
75
sick
the hp 975 also wireless perfectly
appropriate let's start with the generic
wire keyboard this is one of the
cheapest models i was able to find on
amazon and it costs approximately 10 usd
and you know what it actually freaking
works like there's zero set of time
there's no pairing and you don't have to
worry about charging the batteries this
version even has a small power button
that can turn on your desktop computer
and it's also got two risers all you
need to do is plug the usb cable and
you're pretty much good to go and even
as the most basic keyboard
as you'll see compared to other models
this one even has a light indicator that
shows whether cap locks or other
functions are on see i told you you
don't need to spend money on a keyboard
but although it gets the job done you
are left with a bare minimum in terms of
comfort and portability the whole
experience of typing on this keyboard it
does feel very plasticky
and there's a lot of rattle coming from
it and it's also quite loud
if you need to connect this to a laptop
device you will need to sacrifice a usb
port and possibly use a type-c adapter
and of course you can't connect it via
bluetooth to portable devices why isn't
it working anymore oh stupid keyboard
sorry i think i got distracted
idiots
and i know that the sound might not seem
like a big deal
but when you're in a working situation
and you're working around other people
and you're working long hours especially
in stressful situations that sound it
can get kind of irritating especially if
it's coming from someone who's sitting
right next to you and this might seem
kind of like a minute detail but the
way that the space that you're working
in is configured like maybe the size of
the room that can all have an impact on
the reverberation of the keyboard sound
okay let's talk about these two now
this lo-fi playlist is amazing
i'm ready
these two keyboards have one thing in
common they're both wireless and they
both offer a lot of different
functionalities and connectivity options
you can connect via bluetooth 2.4 g
wireless and even a standard usb the new
fee air 75 allows up to four wireless
connections at the same time which means
you can switch between different devices
pretty seamlessly by using a keyboard
shortcut the hp 975 offers three
wireless connections two with bluetooth
and one with a wireless dongle there's
dedicated buttons with light indicators
that show you which connection is
currently active
and both of these keyboards also offer a
usb type-c port this is really great in
situations where you don't want to risk
having any delay or connectivity issues
for example if you're working with a
client or if you're doing a presentation
the wired option gives you the peace of
mind so you don't really have to worry
about battery or responsiveness does it
mean better response time for gaming oh
my god grow up yes of course okay cut
let's have a break
as an architect and now a youtuber i'm
always trying to absorb new information
i don't always have enough time to sit
down and read a full-length book
short form has been great with that tort
form gives you super high quality guides
to non-fiction books and their team of
professional writers synthesize the
information into a single page with very
clear and concise explanations they also
have more in-depth guides that analyze
how it compares to other commonly
accepted ideas for certain books that's
had a very big impact in my life for
example getting things done by david
allen i like to read the short form
summaries from time to time because your
memory just isn't perfect and you will
lose that information over time
now obviously short form
is not a substitute for reading a full
book
but you'd be surprised
how many times i've been tricked into
reading a full book that really could
have been a one-pager
so nowadays every time i get interested
in a book i make sure to go into short
form and read the guides first
just so that i know if it's going to be
worth the investment in my time
also they have a great app
and one of my favorite features is their
audio library
which they're constantly updating
which means i can go for a run and
within like 30 minutes to an hour i can
get pretty much all the lessons that i
need to from a book which is awesome
short form is one of those essential
apps in my phone
that helped me accelerate my growth and
learning by joining through the link
shortform.com stamily you'll receive
five days of unlimited access and an
additional 20 discount off the annual
subscription which is going to give you
access to thousands of book guides for
the price of just one book a month go
check it out
but how does it actually feel to type on
these keyboards
oh my god
i feel like i'm entering a new world i
feel sharp and focused
like a razor blade
the newfie air 75 is a fully mechanical
keyboard and when you get to the
purchasing window you can actually
choose between the different types of
switches you can choose between linear
tactile and clicky i chose the red
linear switch it should be quieter than
the tactile and the clicky switches but
i have to say it is louder compared to
the hp 975 and other keyboards that i've
tried
when i type with a mechanical keyboard i
feel a kind of a deeper connection to
what i'm doing let me explain
it almost seems like hearing some of
that sound is first of all really
satisfying but when i press the keys it
makes me
want to write more what i'm writing is
really hard for me to get into the zone
and this haptic experience of the
keyboard it makes this a little bit more
pleasant
and
i can kind of only compare this to maybe
the experience of writing with a
fountain pen
where you can really feel the drag and
the sound of the pen scratching the
paper
and it's just a totally different
experience from writing with a ball pen
for me these haptic experiences
stimulate a part of the brain that help
with the thinking process in some ways
it feels almost like a tangible
extraction of my thoughts and so when
you start using this mechanical keyboard
i'm pretty sure you're gonna be hooked
not just for doing creative work but for
doing research or filling out forms
or even leaving bad comments on youtube
videos
typing on the new fee is an extremely
haptic experience the rgb lights they
interact with your typing movements and
especially when i'm typing at night in
low light conditions this just totally
elevates my working experience it really
feels like you're becoming one with the
document
what the hell are you doing
mechanical keyboards offer a lot of
customization so you can really choose
the one that suits you the best there's
a lot to talk about here so
all i can say without making a 30 minute
video is that newfie gave me the most
engaging and sensual typing experience
compared to these other models for both
the new fee and the hp 975 there's power
switches on the side of the keyboard and
the new fee also has a switch that
switches between mac and windows the hp
975 has scissor switches and produces a
much quieter clicky kind of sound
people working close to you will barely
notice your typing and it's also very
smooth and a comfortable experience the
biggest difference between the two is
definitely the travel distance of the
keys pushing a scissor switch almost
feels effortless compared to the fully
mechanical keyboard
but for me pushing a mechanical keyboard
is still a little bit more rewarding so
i've been using these two keyboards for
almost a year now and they're both
really great at different tasks and
situations and also on your typing
skills the hp 975 is sleek and silent
and if you are someone who needs to look
at the keys to type is really great for
working in low light conditions the key
caps are optimized for being backlit so
you can actually see the lettering in
the dark another cool thing
it's got a proximity sensor that turns
on the backlight when your hands are
approaching the keys on the other hand
the rgb lights on the new fee are mostly
decorative they don't really improve the
readability in low-light conditions as
long as you're using non-transparent
keycaps and for me it's not really a big
deal because i usually type using muscle
memory but for those of you who need to
look at the keys to type this might be a
bit of an issue the biggest difference
in terms of ergonomics is probably the
positioning of the arrow keys and the
full size numpad on the right which
comes in really handy for me when i'm
doing calculations or spreadsheets
having a dedicated spot for the arrow
keys makes it easier to find and it's
better when you're reviewing long
documents or working with cells and of
course for gaming i don't find the
arrows the arrows find me
clear and obvious
[Music]
just where i like my arrows
the newfie air 75 instead has a much
more compact and portable design it's
optimized more for improving the typing
experience for laptop keyboards and
other smaller devices it's got a premium
aluminum body and a set of special
rubber feet that lets you overlay it on
top of your laptop without interfering
with the keys underneath there's an
optional sleeve that you can use both as
a protective case and as a stand for
tablets and smartphones this is great
when you're traveling and if you have to
type for an extended period of time on
small devices the hp 975 seems better as
a replacement for a desk keyboard since
it's considerably longer and it's got a
more professional look i love that it
has a lot of function keys that you can
customize through the app battery life
is pretty good on both devices but it
could really vary based on your usage
for example if you use it with rgb or
backlight all the time it could drain
the battery a little bit faster but for
me i haven't charged it for weeks and it
seems like it's still going
trying to decide on a hundred dollar
plus keyboard may seem like a first
world problem but it is true that a
keyboard is something that we use for
eight hours a day almost every day and
so having one that suits our needs and
makes the typing experience more
pleasant is definitely not just a luxury
but it is an investment that you should
take some time to consider for me
there's no
clear winner i'm constantly switching
between them
based on whether i'm doing creative work
or traveling or office work let me know
in the comments what type of keyboard
you use also i have some great content
about architecture and design and
creativity i'll leave a playlist right
here and with that i'll see you guys in
the next video
i'm not really made for this can you
repeat that can you please be quiet i'm
trying to focus here
pdf me
what do you mean pdf me
nobody pdfs me
don't you dare say you're gonna pdf me
you